unbelievable joining me now Victor Davis
Hanson senior fellow at the Hoover
Institute in Charlie heard Washington
Times opinion editor and Fox News
contributor first on the 250 million
dollar Bond Charlie I guess the way it
works he only has to put up no money
it's his mom's house worth 4 million the
250 million means absolutely nothing
well yeah and it's supposedly you know
the way these Bond things are supposed
to work is you're supposed to put up uh
10 collateral which would be 25 million
dollars and apparently that's not the
deal what's happening here but here's
the other thing that sort of just
boggles my mind is the idea that that
you know the theory of the case that
prosecutors are making is that he
fleeced all of his investors in order to
buy property for himself and his family
including the house that his parents
live in and so you're able to put up
your ill-gotten gains in order to Spring
you out of jail on bail it makes no
sense
Victor Davis Hanson this is your area
this is where he lives this is where you
work how's this playing in Silicon
Valley
oh I don't think he's one of their own I
mean this whole thing has been
mysterious why didn't they just do a you
know an Enron five million dollar Bond
and he puts up 500 000 but they wanted a
virtue signal that they were very hard
on this guy without being hard on him at
all and it's remember Brian he was
gradually going broke to paraphrase
Hemingway and then suddenly he went
broke right after the election and we
didn't know what was going on I wish we
had known that before the midterm and
then suddenly he was going to testify
for six hours and then suddenly he was
he was indicted and so he's been given
special treatment all the way Along by
the left and he's part of this triangle
and on one base of the triangle you've
got seven trillion dollars in market
capitalization in Facebook and Twitter
and Apple and Google and on the other is
Stanford University that gives you the
patina of prestige and which gave us
Elizabeth Holmes and the theranos it
gave us Carolyn Ellison his Alameda CEO
who's turning States evidence it gave us
the bankman professors who were very
active and his I think his FTX scam and
then the Third Leg of course is the Bay
Area left-wing political machine of
Gavin Newsom Nancy Pelosi Kamala Harris
Etc Dianne Feinstein so you put all
three together and they exercise a lot
of power and they're exempt from the
rules that apply to everybody else due
to prestige money and political power
and influence but
hey Charlie before you comment I know
you have a lot to say here I want people
to remember who aren't following this
close who aren't invested in crypto and
kind of scared off by it like let's say
me here's the here is uh this guy the
these prominent Democrats talking about
how valuable he's been to their
campaigns in their party uh members of
the media talking about how much they
love this guy watch
29 year old gazillionaire FTX founder
and CEO Sam bankman freed I love you Sam
I'm just jealous Sam Bachman freed is
very smart the the book value here is
seven billion they have they have cash
on on the books of like six billion some
on Twitter calling him the hero right
now of the industry there's comparisons
to Warren Buffett back in the financial
crisis
and you know it's pretty uh pretty
amazing is I I think he gave most of the
money went to Democrats a handful went
to Republicans and they say he gave to
both sides you were just like Zucker
bucks were evenly distributed yeah no
it's absolutely incredible and that sort
of explains why because he sprinkled
that money not just among Democrats but
also among uh media operations and which
probably is the big reason why even
after he was exposed he went on that
extraordinary media tour just a month
ago uh basically saying that oh you know
like as you played with the clip with
George Stephanopoulos he just wasn't he
wasn't he wasn't devoting enough of his
honest self to the operation that's
that's where the breakdown occurred but
the most important thing here in all of
this is how and when the the politicians
to whom he gave tens of millions of
dollars to when will those politicians
how will those politicians be forced to
return every dime of that money so that
that money can be restored to the people
that he fleeced it from
Victor real quick it looks like he's in
a lot of trouble Caroline Ellison
cooperated and pleaded guilty of four
charges Gary Wang the co-founder pleaded
guilty to multiple charges too they're
going to give up the goods on this guy
they want him they're looking they're
all looking at over 100 years in prison
how does this turn out being that he's
got so many powerful friends
I I'm I'll have to uh see it to believe
it because he went on his little uh PR
tour he's got the ramshackle look like
all uh billionaires in Silicon Valley do
he's connected to Stanford University
his parents are law professors he's been
given soft gloves treatment and I think
he's just going to plead all Shucks I
really didn't know it was going I was so
busy trying to help everybody I didn't
know that I'd heard I'm so sorry and I
think that might be effective with a
jury especially
with good legal representation so he
belongs behind bars if he's guilty and I
think he is but I don't want to prejudge
him but so far he's been given
asymmetrical treatment compared to what
most people suffer in this country when
they commit a crime or they're alleged
to commit a crime of that magnitude
yeah we're upset at smashing grabs and
we should be in San Francisco when we
lose a hundred thousand dollars or
twenty thousand dollars this guy lost
over a billion and he affected a million
people when those people start speaking
up this guy should be going away forever
where eventually he'll probably probably
be forced to comb his hair uh Victor
Charlie thanks so much great to see you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else